immediate action really helps you know
that when you get an idea trust that the
idea is good and then do something about
it to build momentum because I think for
a lot of people the only thing they're
missing is momentum the key is like you
got to take action while you are in that
moment in that zone and what great
coaches will do is then also give you
homework to do and then you you push
them to do the thing because it's in
their best interest and so I think
people take 10 years to take the first
step and it's about getting momentum
going cuz once you have momentum it's a
lot easier to keep going but building
that momentum taking that first step is
really difficult